[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce cette fuite sport
les magazines et qu'on serait comme vous
le savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département c'est parti à pour le
sommaire baseball ce dimanche 10 juin
les cougars de montigny-le-bretonneux
ont soufflé le chaud et le froid
domicile ils ont perdu la première
manche contre les barracuda de
montpellier mais ont remporté la seconde
partie les détails dans ce magazine box
gallus coulon de la team farruggia
d'elancourt s'est incliné avec les
honneurs contre le numéro trois européen
s'endort martin le samedi 2 joue en
espagne
nous recevrons le saint quentinois sur
ce plateau dans quelques instants avec
son entraîneur tandis farrugia apnée un
record est tombé ce week end à saint cyr
l'école le franco cubain handicadres
érable il a réussi 395 longueur en trois
heures dans l'eau une performance qu'il
a réalisée dans une piscine remplie de
détritus pour sensibiliser les personnes
à la pollution des océans en reportage à
suivre
on ouvre maintenant une large page
résultats
[Musique]
direction tout de suite les terrains de
baseball et cougar de montigny le
bretonneux recevait les barracuda de
montpellier à ce dimanche dans leur
stade jean maréchal un choc entre le
leader et le 3e du championnat qui s'est
soldé par une défaite une victoire des
signes montrent un des images de à
nicolas landry les cougars de montigny
le bretonneux ont connu des montagnes
russes émotionnelles ce dimanche 10 juin
contre les barracuda de montpellier le
leader de 1re division
dans leur stade jean maréchal lésiné
montain se sont inclinés dans la
première partie de la journée si sa
douche
mais ils ont récité leur baseball ils
ont ils ont été infidèle à eux mêmes à
savoir voilà faire courir les joueurs
sur base profiter des moindres erreurs
qu'on leur a donné de l'autre
de leur côté aussi ils ont fait quelques
erreurs mais on n'a pas su les punir
pour ça et c'est pour ça que à la fin
voilà on rit on risque de revenir mais
c'est trop tard on doit pas se
concentrer
on doit être plus fort que ça après une
discussion franche sur le terrain les
cougars se reprennent et valide la
victoire sur le score de 14 à 4 l'après
midi cette première défaite de la
journée laisse des regrets
comme je le dis souvent à mes joueurs
est comme gelée encore dit aujourd'hui
notre premier adversaire c'est nous
mêmes et si on n'arrive pas à se
concentrer sur ce qu'on a à faire on ne
peut pas gagner des matches et c'est
vraiment c'est ce genre de match ils
sont intenses puisque on joue contre le
premier on a des places sont à une place
de premier à les chercher
c'est vrai que c'est vraiment important
les pédophiles sont ils sont à notre
portée mais là on cherche vraiment le
titre donc si on n'arrive pas à gérer ce
type de match ça va être compliqué mais
je suis sûr qu'on va qu'on va pouvoir
remonter au classement les cougars de
montigny le bretonneux reprennent la
deuxième place et pointe à deux
victoires de montpellier qui reste
leader
l'équipe signé monteyne est toujours
qualifié pour les playoffs de fin de
saison
dans les autres résultats du week-end
dans les yvelines ont joué sur les
terrains de handball dans son match de
barrage pour l'accession à la nationale
2 plaisir s'est finalement incliné sur
terrain neutre contre molsheim après
avoir mené la partie pendant plus de 40
minutes score final 27 à 26 les héninois
resteront donc en nationale 3 l'année
prochaine après avoir terminé deuxième
l'objectif initial de la saison pour le
promu est donc atteint on a déjà hâte de
les retrouver en septembre
en rugby un très gros match également
joué à ce week-end après un superbe
parcours verset s'est incliné ce
dimanche en quart de finale du
championnat de france contre chalon sur
saône sur terrain neutre
les joueurs de la cité royale ont été
battus 1
à zéro avec un manque d'efficacité au
pied qui leur coûte le match dé
versailles et pourrait tout de même
monté cette année si les descentes
administratives sont enregistrés pour
cette fin de saison
un mot de boxe à présent gallus coulon
de l'altima farrugia des landes pour
s'est incliné avec les honneurs contre
sandor martin le samedi 2 juin en
espagne
le numéro deux européen 30 victoires
dont 11 par ko et 2 défaites a été mis
en grande difficulté par le saint
quentinois pour nous parler de ce combat
nous recevons sur ce plateau le grand
acteur de cette partie gallus coulon
ainsi que son coach ce temps guy
farrugia
bonsoir je vois alors comment vous vous
sentez gallus depuis ce combat bien très
sincèrement le combat il a pas été à
sens unique comme de nombreuses
personnes auraient pu le penser dans le
sens où j'ai eu pas mal d'échos parce
que les gens ont toujours des avis faut
pas y aller tu es fou
tu finiras suffira tu feras des routes
et 3 ou 4 voilà ça va ça finira pas ou
donc là sur ce combat là en été c'était
sur environ avaient signée au niveau du
contraste d'un monde qui était prévu et
j'ai fait je suis parti j'ai fait le
travail qu'il y avait à faire on savait
en y allant que
fallait fallait c'était pas cherché le
ko parce qu'il faut boxer sinon on est
crispé et le combat n'avance pas donc on
à boxer intelligemment tactiquement
donc j'ai fait le combat qu'il fallait
maintenant on était chez lui donc
il ya des petits avantages qu'on n'a pas
forcément pu avoir parce qu'il était
chez lui donc entre guillemets un petit
peu favorisés au niveau de l'arbitrage
notamment par exemple au troisième round
ou
je prends un avertissement pour eux
d'après l'arbitré vous à déstabiliser
déstabiliser non parce que bon le coach
il est là aussi
tanguy pour pour parle du mans flammes
et que je m'énerve donc non j'ai j'ai
continué de lui confier le combat il m'a
dit cela on est notre techniquement
quand on prend un avertissement sur un
run de le rhône il est perdu donc le
travail du coach aussi étaient là de
calme et de ne pas pour pas que je me
dise pas c'est que je reste concentré
mais c'est un très beau combat il a eu
très peur parce que très sincèrement je
pense qu'il sait à 10 attendais pas
un adversaire de demain de ma trempe
entre guillemets dans le sens où après
le combat il a reconnu que c'est un
meilleur débat très dur c'est un combat
très dur pour lui maintenant il était
chez lui ailleurs ça aurait été sûrement
un autre
une autre issue mais on était chez lui
et c'était soit le cas où on savait en y
allant que c'était soit le cas où ça
serait un peu compliqué au niveau aussi
c'était serré au niveau du combat en lui
même temps me faro jazz qui peut avoir
des regrets gallus sur cette rencontre
franchement dans aucune on allait on est
numéro 7 français on arrivait pour
rencontrer le futur challenger européen
via lui ça va on a voulu prendre sa
place
il a fait ce qu'il a fait ce qu'il a pu
manque un peu d'expérience mais après
l'arbitrage est toujours toujours à
domicile c'est toujours assez dur
reconnaît voilà donc dit qu'on arrivait
au corps à corps
j'aurais préféré que galice leur
encontre en france franchement
aujourd'hui
ouais aujourd'hui 6 à refaire et si on a
les moyens de le faire j'aimerais bien
le faire en france
ce combat là ce match est il vu comme
une victoire gallus quelque part oui
parce que j'ai derrière j'ai pu moi me
classer au niveau européen et voir que
finalement vraiment j'ai le niveau après
ya toujours du travail à faire derrière
pour pour passer certains cas et c'est
pour du travail technique etc
mais vraiment j'ai vu que s'il n'y avait
pas un n'y avait pas ce n'était pas un
fossé qui avait entre les hommes de tête
du championnat du sud d'europe tout
simplement et et moi quoi donc oui oui
c'est une victoire quelque part
maintenant étant un compétiteur et
compte twitter que je suis le résultat
attendu n'est pas là donc quand même
s'il est évident il ya quand même une
déception
tanguy vous pensez que khamis a encore
un bel avenir devant lui vous pensez que
ce combat peut lui servir pour les
prochains à les prochaines rencontres
servir dans le sens je pense qu'il a
commencé à prendre conscience de ses
capacités
oui maintenant nous desservir parce que
maintenant la france a peur de gallus et
on aura du mal à organiser ces combats
physiquement vous pensez que vous avez
encore un palier à franchir où vous
étiez bien physiquement
physiquement j'étais très bien le régime
a été très bien gérée maintenant je
connais depuis le temps que je suis dans
le circuit
maintenant cinq ans professionnel je
connais très bien mon corps donc au
niveau des du régime ça s'est très bien
passé j'étais en gt frais sur le sur
leur et il n'y avait pas de 40
particulières ou de pépins physiques
particuliers quand j'étais et vous
arrivez à tenir contre un peuple
européen
c'est ça c'était numéro 2 donc donc ça
peut être un nouveau objectif très bien
aussi c'est tout à fait ça si un
objectif maintenant derrière
pour organiser c'est pareil à l'argent
il faut de l'argent il faut il faut des
sponsors donc
donc voilà c'est un toit après qui
permet de de faire une organisation à
domicile par exemple les laisse coulon
actuellement neuf victoires 10 défaites
et un nul à 27 ans tanguy c'est quoi la
suite pour gallus gallus ça va l'aider
fait de viser un titre repas comme on le
disait quelques instants alors les
défaites ils ont toujours été chez les
adversaires il ya deux cas elle qui est
champion de france actuel à des welters
via l'uci en super légers il ya bassolé
qui a fait les jeux olympiques est
pareil c'était chez lui on a comme on
appelle ça à toutes les majorités de ces
défaites sont des défaites à part
reconnu donc si on a les moyens on nous
donne les moyens d'organiser ici le
titre national et au niveau européen oui
je pense que je gagne on nous attendait
pas à ce niveau là on nous a donné
l'opportunité je sais qu'il ya eue s'il
est capable
wesh champion d'europe est sûre demain
nous propose le championnat d'europe je
il ya des sous les combats trop
rapidement cette victoire
oui bien sûr oui c'est anguilles en
pourparlers avec d éventuels un éventuel
combat à venir donc oui il faut remonter
tout sur le ring pour payet facile si je
pourrais dire cette défaite
et oui oui je suis dès septembre après
après les 70 peut-être même pas
peut-être même pas peut-être avant ça
dépend de des opportunités qui se
présentent à nous et
pareil si l'on ressent pour parler donc
peut-être avant septembre
merci à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau
on continue rassure avec attention vos
résultats et du sco long et on vous
souhaite de renouer avec la victoire le
plus rapidement possible merci beaucoup
on va maintenant parler football j - 4
avant le début de la coupe du monde en
russie mercredi dernier l'équipe de
france s'est entraînée une dernière fois
en public au centre technique national
de clairefontaine dans le sud des
yvelines plus de mille supporters
tricolores s'étaient déplacés pour
encourager une dernière fois les bleus
avant leur départ les footballeurs
français en ont profité pour signer
quelques autographes et prendre quelques
selphy nous étions sur place pour
recueillir les réactions
il ya du monde ça fait plaisir et nous
soutiennent voilà on est soutenus non on
est soutenus les a pas
voilà toujours un peu je rencontre les
supporters on passe un bon moment avec
la france jouera son premier match de la
coupe du monde ce dimanche à midi contre
l'australie jo-2000 24 à présent un
déplacement les épreuves à l'hippodrome
de longchamp était évoquée depuis
quelques semaines
finalement ce sera bien le château de
versailles qui accueillera la
compétition d'équitation pour les jeux
olympiques 2024 à paris le comité
d'organisation vient de confirmer son
choix l'objectif annoncé mettre en avant
les sites historiques et emblématique de
paris sa banlieue
versailles sera également le théâtre les
épreuves de cyclisme sur route et de
pentathlon moderne pour les jo de 2024
je vous conseille à présent de retenir
votre souffle un record date n'est
tombée ce week-end à saint-cyr-l'ecole
le franco cubain andy cabreira avila a
qu'a réussi à 395 longueur en trois
heures dans l'eau une performance qu'il
a réalisée la réaliser dans une piscine
remplie de détritus pour sensibiliser
les personnes à la pollution des océans
des images de signer à nicolas d'henri
des ballons des bouteilles des sacs en
plastique c'est dans cette décharge
fictive que le franco cubain andy
cabreira villa voulait tenter son
nouveau record d'apnée ce dimanche 10
juin objectif dénoncer la pollution des
océans se glissant dans la peau d'un
mammifère marin qui a plus de 300
millions de tonnes des déchets de
plastique dans les océans
donc c'est un vide endossant déchets par
minute ça à dire plus et sans déchet par
seconde
synchrone à tout le monde est menacé
contre un professeur d'un océan et ça
c'est génial
pourquoi c'est important de lutter
contre la pollution des océans pas
question pour moi j'ai de quoi soit on
pourra peut aller à la mer soit on
continue ça va trop pollué la peur et
après on va mourir d'un second à trois
roues l'objectif est également sportif
l'apnéiste 46 ans doit réaliser au
minimum trois cent soixante cinq
longueurs en trois ans reprenant sa
respiration tous les 25 mètres pas
facile quand les déchets flottent à la
surface serait très compliqué parce
qu'il sert à rien at-il un âge j'ai
peut-être va même aller
parmi les sacs en plastique et symboles
symboles et les méduses à laquelle les
tortues y mange les plastiques et pense
que sa mère de six morts
donc oui c'est rare à lundi la nage mais
c'est pas grave c'est moi qui a décidé
question comme ça dû au jeu le jeu et
j'assume ou andy cabreira ville a
finalement parcouru en trois heures 395
longueur l'équivalent de 9 875 km un
record pour la bonne cause qu'il
pourrait de nouveau amélioré dans les
prochains mois petite rectification le
match l'équipe de france saura bien à ce
samedi à midi contre l'australie après
avoir plongé en apnée je vous propose de
prendre de la vitesse dans cette
émission âgé de 38 ans le gluant
courtois stéphane panepinto a terminé
cinquième du vvv endurance sur le
circuit provençal du paul ricard pour sa
première expérience au volant d'une
proto lmp2 3 nous avons la chance de
recevoir le pilote stéphane panepinto
sur ce plateau bonsoir ou sans michael
alors comment ça s'est passé sur ça ça a
été ça a été compliqué au début parce
qu'on a eu des petits problèmes
mécaniques
donc ça m'a empêché de faire de profiter
pleinement des essais libres et donc de
m'adapter à la voiture puisque c'était
ma première course dans cette catégorie
là pas mal de choses à assimiler pour
pouvoir penser être performant et donc
j'ai bénéficié de vintimille dure tout
de suite si je comprends et et voilà
très compliqué à la pression tout de
suite d'entrée et du coup je suis parti
pour mon relais sans vraiment avoir les
connaissances de la voiture est ce que
cette cinquième place est un bon
résultat
c'est un très bon résultat c'est ce
qu'on s'était dit avec avec mes
coéquipiers on espérait faire cette
position au mieux on n'envisageait pas
plus parce qu'on connaît notre niveau et
ça nos adversaires et donc on a réussi
notre challenge vous auriez pu aller
peut-être un tout petit peu plus haut
dans le classement sur le podium
cette soirée était compliquée parce que
encore une fois on manquait d'expérience
dans cette catégorie on était face à des
adversaires qui avaient plusieurs
saisons dans les bourgs des plus rusés
et à une bonne maîtrise de la voiture
donc on sait que dans ce sport est comme
dans beaucoup de sports d'ailleurs la
pratique fait que l'on assimile les
compétences et quand vous êtes vous
senti sur cette première course
justement stressé je sais pas vu que
c'était votre premier rang elle mp3 au
début oui toujours stressé avant de
monter dans la voiture une fois qu'on
est dedans on a le casque on est
concentrés on pense plus à autre chose
ont juste à s'appliquer et à faire une
bonne performance
comment se sent quand on va 257 km heure
c'était votre vitesse maximale sur le
circuit c'était la vitesse maximale que
j'ai que j'ai que j'ai pris
effectivement en 61 des fois c'était sur
ce circuit le ruisseau sinon ça ça
atteint les 300 km heure sur des
circuits un peu avec des plus longues
lignes droites
donc là bas on se sent déjà on est
concentrés donc on n'a pas forcément le
temps de penser à beaucoup de choses
parce qu'on arrive très rapidement au
point de freinage et on freine à peu
près 90 m à ce moment là pour négocier
un virage à 60 kilomètres/heure donc on
a à peu près 200 km de décélération en
90 m alors vous avez fait vous fait du
karting depuis vos quinze ans et ce qui
est une énorme différence un fossé entre
le karting et la lmp 3 effectivement
c'est déjà la vitesse change beaucoup de
choses le poids également et la
technique de pilotage et
vraiment différente donc pour faire
rapide sur un kart
on a deux roues qui sont sur le même
arbre à l'arrière qui sont fixés sur les
marbres et en voiture on a des
différentiels donc déjà ça ça demande
une technique différente et on a un
transfert de masse qui se fait en
voiture grâce aux amortisseurs qu'on n'a
pas en kart donc ces deux éléments déjà
change la donne
alors physiquement est-ce qu'il faut
plus d'entraînement oui forcément ça va
plus vite
sa demande sera moins d'entraînements
physiques ipp beaucoup beaucoup
d'entraînement physique d'ailleurs je le
dis honnêtement j'étais pas vraiment
prêt sur cette course je m'attendais pas
à cette difficulté à dire vous n'avez
pas m'étaler d'expérience sur cette
course surtout pas assez préparés
physiquement j'ai pas fait assez de
sport
j'ai un travail à côté qui me prend
aussi beaucoup de temps donc c'était
compliqué mais du coup j'en profite pour
ceux qui qui en espère le faire un jour
de bien se préparer avant une course
mois et physiquement du coup vous êtes
préparés comme physiquement ben j'avais
fait un peu de footing un peu de pondre
des abdos chez moi mais voilà c'était
c'était vraiment pas suffisant pour
pouvoir être performant comme j'aurais
dû l'être
comment on sort d'un une compétition
comme celle là on est sorti on en sort
grandie vous étiez prêts à faire un
marathon derrière où j'étais un très
facile j'étais un peu fatigué
effectivement mais la douleur est
rapidement passé donc c'est vrai que
grâce au carton j'ai quand même à six
mines et enfin pas mal de choses donc
une bonne formation aussi physique pour
pour ce sport donc je me suis vite remis
quels sont les secteurs qu'il faudra
encore améliorer sur les prochains
courses qui vont arriver vite
oui bah moi ça va être c'est mon
physique tout de suite c'est vraiment la
chose la plus importante après ça va
être de pouvoir rouler aussi pour
pouvoir mieux me préparer techniquement
dans la voiture et et puis déjà ça sera
déjà un bon pas vous étiez sur un
circuit mythique accueillera le grand
prix de f1 dans quelques semaines la
semaine prochaine la semaine prochaine
justement est-ce que c'est un rêve pour
vous
d'être sur ce circuit paul ricard alors
j'ai déjà eu la chance de rouler sur ce
circuit sur les world series en maserati
j'avais fini 3e
donc mais c'est toujours un plaisir de
rouler sur ce type de circuit c'est
vraiment c'est on atteint des hautes
vitesses
on a des passages en courbes qui sont
extrêmement rapides des gros freinages
donc c'est vrai que c'est toujours un
plaisir d'avoir côtoyé ce circuit
plusieurs fois d'avoir évolution saluée
l'a plusieurs fois est ce que ça vous a
aidé dans cette course
oui j'avais déjà et les notions de
trajectoire même si d'une gt à un proto
c'est totalement différent déjà dans la
position pour là on est dans la voiture
donc ça change champ de vision est donc
faut se réadapter mais bon je savais
déjà où je devais tourner quel est votre
objectif maintenant vous avez terminé
cinquième
l'objectif c'est de faire mieux je
suppose c'est toujours de faire mieux
bien sûr mais l'objectif c'est déjà de
pouvoir participer à d'autres à d'autres
courses la prochaine ce sera au mois
d'octobre sur le circuit bugatti au mans
et ce sera déjà un premier pied sur mon
objectif principal qui est de participer
aux 24 heures du mans en lmp2 qui est
une catégorie supérieure
c'est réalisable de participer aux 24
heures du mans c'est réalisable ça
demande beaucoup de travail parce qu'il
faut rechercher des partenaires donc ça
c'est un autre métier c'est un deuxième
métier et
si tout est mis à bout à bout c'est
faisable d'autres pilotes se font donc
ça doit être faisable et c'est un sacré
vous connaissez bien aussi celui des 24
heures du mans
j'ai jamais roulé sur celui des 24
heures du mans mais sur le bugatti j'ai
déjà roulé effectivement mais du coup là
sur les 24 heures du mans ils
élargissent sur le circuit routier donc
celui-ci je ne connais pas encore alors
vous avez 38 ans est ce qui ne devrait
tarder à avoir des résultats
faux moi ça reste un loisir une passion
j'ai pas d'objectif de carrière elle est
loin derrière
donc j'ai encore largement le temps de
pouvoir réaliser cet objectif
maintenant j'ai envie de le faire
rapidement j'aimerais bien fêter mes 40
ans dans la voiture et vous comptez
rouler jusqu'à quel âge
tant que je pourrai votre objectif à ça
serait les 24 heures du mans 24 heures
du mans une première fois peut-être une
deuxième une troisième
merci à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau
on vous le souhaite en tout cas de
participer aux 24 heures du mans merci
beaucoup et bon courage pour le
financement aussi de aux prochaines
épreuves
merci merci beaucoup cyclisme à présent
la 15e édition de la monty cyclo s'est
déroulée ce samedi 9 juin au départ du
centre sportif pierre de coubertin à
montigny le bretonneux
au programme trois parcours 100 150 et
200 km à travers les yvelines en passant
par des lieux historiques et des villes
comme dans pire encore montfort l'amaury
rendez vous qui a attiré plusieurs
centaines de participants écoutent les
réactions à l'arrivée au micro de notre
journaliste nicolas d'ambri bas on a
bien roulé a fait une bonne moyenne
la partie vite à leur retour un peu
moins que le vent de face mais elle vend
donc j'ai un peu moins vite sinon au
départ
c'est pas mal des bonnes jambes pas
forcément mais enfin minimum de jambes
pour d'expérience on se lance pour la
première fois comme ça c'est sûr le
parcours était très roulant pas trop
donner de dénivelé donc en groupe avec
les copains ça se fait bien les 100km
range maintenant les vélos pour parler
de golf après le numéro un mondiale
justin thomas c'est une autre star qui
foulera les greens du golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines
l'espagnol sergio garcia vainqueur du
masters 100 2017 et de 32 titres sur le
circuit mondiaux a officialisé sa venue
sur le plus grand tournoi français à
quelques mois de la ryder cup
ce sera une grande première pour ce
membre du top 15 mondial on regarde la
réaction qu'il a publiées sur les
réseaux sociaux
je suis très excité d'annoncer ma venue
au à chennai open de france à la fin du
mois j'ai une chance de jouer au golf
national un parcours incroyable qui va
accueillir la ryder cup plus tard dans
l'année
enfin je ne peux pas attendre de voir
les fabuleux supporters français cette
semaine là et pour la ryder cup
ensemble on va essayer de ramener le
trophée
j'ai hâte de vous voir là-bas prenez
soin et ce n'est pas la première fois
que sergio garcia joue un tournoi en
france et dans les yvelines l'espagnol a
participé à cinq reprises au trophée
lancôme entre 1995 et 2002 a rendez-vous
hébergé par le golf 2 à saint nom la
bretèche serge garcia reviendra
peut-être dans les mines pour participer
à la ryder cup le rendez-vous sera
organisé du 28 au 30 septembre à saint
quentin en yvelines pour vous immerger
dès à présent dans la compétition tb 70
2 vous propose de découvrir chaque lundi
des anecdotes sportive sur le tournoi
aujourd'hui le président de la
fédération française de golf jaune
charron vous le nous livre l'un de ses
souvenirs regarder
[Musique]
je me souviens la ryder cup 2010 katic
manor ma première haider cup
il pleut un temps absolument comme on a
dans les îles britanniques
je prends le premier jour de compétition
je prends le bus à 6 heures du matin
avec une heure de route pour arriver à
cette heure sur place toujours une pluie
battante le but pour moi est de voir le
coup d'envoi le premier drive de cette
édition de la ryder cup et j'arrive au
ty numéro un les tribunes pleines à
craquer donc debout autour du tilloy et
dans 5 6e rang position et puis pleut on
attend bien qu'ouvert à être l'hôte du
pli arrivent les équipes qui vont partir
les parts puis sont bien évidemment
ouvert pour protéger sa blague entre les
sa chambre un peu comme on dit et puis
au moment où le joueur se met à
l'adresse tous les parents puissent
ferme pour permettre à tout le monde de
voir ce drive de lancement de la ryder
cup et voyez rien d'en parler joue
encore la scène ça me donne toujours des
fritons c'est mon premier souvenir de
ryder cup c'est éreintant
j'ai adoré ce respect qui existe envers
tout le monde chacun regarde sedan
arrivé aussitôt les parapluies sont
ouverts
[Musique]
on referme ce magazine par trois
rendez-vous qu'il nous faudra absolument
pas manquer ce week-end dans les
yvelines à elancourt 350 coureurs
s'élanceront du stade andré boniface
pour participer à la 7ème édition des 10
km de la ville
sur le plan sportif cette épreuve
comptera pour le championnat
départemental d i mean et sera ouverte à
tous à partir de 16 ans le départ sera
donné à 20 heures précises
toujours à elancourt la revancharde
fêtera ce dimanche 17 juin ses 20 ans la
course de vtt proposera une nouvelle
fois à plus de 200 participants âgés de
13 à 77 ans de gravir la colline
d'elancourt le point culminant de l'île
de france qui accueillera les jo de 2024
le public pour assister à la
manifestation les bénéfices sont
reversés comme chaque année aux
orphelins des sapeurs pompiers
et puis il y aura du golfe ce samedi 16
juin saint quentin en yvelines avec la
golf expérience le rendez-vous proposera
à 100 jours de la ryder cup du practice
sur loup un tapis sur dimensionné pour
faire des potes et des ateliers d'
approche golfique à montigny le
bretonneux
les participants pourront également
tester le disc-golf un dérivé de
l'ultimate frisbee vous rendez vous sont
organisés gratuitement devant la
médiathèque du canal c'est la fin de
cette émission merci d'avoir suivi on se
retrouve lundi prochain pour un nouveau
magazine d'ici là passez une excellente
semaine sportive très belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]